hey what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome to episode 64 of game
programming so last time we took a look
at a very very basic and I guess minimal
and simplistic way of handling collision
and it was simply one line of code
basically and that just said to test a
simple very very simple thing
leveled agate tile if if the tile that
we want to advance to is solid then
don't let us go there alright pretty
simple rights of collision if a
collision actually does come this is
actually probably incorrect because it
says if there's not a collision oh yeah
let's cry sorry if it's oh there's not a
collision let's move so let's just
launch that and see what that does so
these tiles over here a solid can we
walk into them no we cannot and if I go
up here then we can't we can't open to
them so sweet it light right it works
now it doesn't well it does work and I
mean I don't want to tell you guys that
it doesn't work because it does work
right but what up what we want to do is
kind of control it a bit more so what
we're going to cover today is going to
be pretty simple right
all we're going to cover today is we're
going to talk about how we can make sure
that if we actually are colliding the
science believe that example is horrible
go down here if we are actually
colliding with something like this thing
here we can't move up and down right we
can move up and down now but if I am
actually colliding with it and I try and
move down look at that we can't move
down and we can't move up why not
and also we collide into something like
that we cannot move left and right right
I'm pressing the buttons we can't move
left and right why not that's a bit of a
problem
because I like sliding and I guess this
is called sliding but what I mean is I
like rubbing up against a wall that
sounds wrong but I'm worried what I mean
is I love just being able to go up to a
wall and just slide across it and I
can't do that in this game that we've
made so far and that's not good so we're
going to talk about fixing that today
and then next time next episode we'll
take a look at actually refining this
collision detection method to make it a
bit more precise and but more
importantly give us more control over
what area is solid because at the moment
you can see that we kind of
our King Cherno sprite here kind of you
know is halfway through this little wall
you can see that actually it is exactly
halfway I think and we you know we sort
of want to want to be able to move it
back and say that okay that is
collidable don't let them go past that
and basically what we want to be able to
do is not only shift this area that is
collidable but also maybe you widen it
or narrow it in some cases and that's
what we'll talk about in the next
episode but this episode we'll talk
about that sliding thing I talked about
so sliding how does it work it's really
simple
alright it is really simple basically
what we've got right now is one
expression we say that if that's not
really an expression is it I guess it's
cool or no one's called actually I
should probably know this um it was a
boolean expression I guess you could
call it a boolean expression but we've
got this one little test here and it
says that if there is no collision in
either of those terminals then make sure
movement works right and that's all cool
but the thing is sometimes right there
is collision in one but not the other in
this case if I move up here and go back
we should always change our spawn
location showing away okay as you can
see that's the x-axis right this is the
y-axis if I go on the x-axis I'm
colliding on the x-axis and what this
code over here says is that if there is
a collision on either of the axis then
don't let the person move that's why I
can't move that's that's the problem all
right you can say how simple it is so
all I really need to do is separate them
and there's two ways of doing that
there's one way and I can simply say
that if there's a collision in ooh let's
just say hmm well we could separate this
out in two ways I can save there's a
collision in X ay and that equals zero
then you know it doesn't sorry if
there's no collision in X ay we can move
X ay but if there's a collision and why
a then
around you know we could do it that way
and if we test if this works so you can
see that I can actually move on one axis
and if I come over here I can actually
slide across so that's one way of doing
it that's not the way that I like doing
it but that is one way of doing it yeah
so you can see that you can slide up and
down it perfectly now so we can do
pretty cool stuff like this corner stuff
and that's pretty awesome so there we go
that's that problem fixed that's one of
the ways of fixing it there is one other
way though because this kind of just
separates them into two of statements
and that kind of works but what we can
do is separate the entire movement
system and I'm actually just thinking
right now that would be faster or slower
in terms of performance but I'm not sure
so let's just do it anyway so what I
could do is I could actually retain it
as it was before which is like this all
right
so in other words we go back to what we
had before but what I could say is
instead of you know moving on to us at
once I could simply say that if if we
are moving if X a doesn't equal 0 and Y
a doesn't equal zero right what does
that mean that means that we're actually
trying to move on to access at once
all right so in other words if I just
proved my point here by printing we are
moving on to axis look putting
exclamation marks everywhere but anyway
you can see that if I move normally now
just up and down I'm going to work but
if I move diagonally look at that it
says well move on to access so in other
words if we are moving on both X a and Y
then we can simply separate this and say
let's move it X a and let's move it on Y
a separately of course all right so what
I'm doing here is I'm saying let's just
redo that entire thing again but this
time let's just do it set let's run it
twice let's run it once for the ax and
one once for the Y and the reason the
reason we do this is because it's
probably a bit
I'm just thinking hmm and I guess but
also we could return it should return
anyway that's thing I'm not sure if it
would actually it's actually good hmm
let's just that right now
getting a bit off-topic here but I'm
actually generally interested does this
run I guess it yeah it does well in that
case we should definitely return all
right so we basically return just gets
out of the method you guys should know
that but anyway you can see now that
what I've done in here is I've separated
and I'll explain that in a minute but
yeah there we go
so we still get that sliding movement
with one little thing here all right so
let's talk about this quickly and and
then that's it so basically what we've
done here is we've said that if we are
advancing on two axes we're just going
to split it up so we're going to run the
what we're going to run this entire
method once just for the x axis and then
we're going to run at another time just
for the y axis and that way obviously
you know y is going to equal zero in the
in axis case and x is going to equal
zero on what in y's case which is why
it's going to process this collision
separately for two different axes so
really I showed you guys two methods
today and you guys can use either of
those methods as you know because
they're armed well they're exactly the
same like they I don't think there's
actually a difference in performance
either there might be I don't know I'll
have to look that up if you guys
actually see that there's a difference
in performance let me know because I
don't have time to check that stuff out
but anyway the point is that is how we
can do sliding and next time we'll talk
about we'll talk about the more advanced
way of colliding almost normally in more
advanced ways just building on this way
but what I mean is a much more
controllable and customizable wavelet of
handling collision detection and
response anyway guys I'll see you guys
next time hope you enjoyed this episode
of game programming if you did please
hit that like button and I will see you
guys next time goodbye